you get to control the level of the
situation as opposed to you know these
guys you see all of our conservative
shows and radio really yeah I go to the
eyes I go for the throat cuz I'm not
limited by sport well actually you're so
limited because you can only make it
work if you can get to the eyes and like
end someone's life well not to mention I
know you know where my eyes are and I
know where your eyes are and balls and
anything bottom line is whatever you can
do dirty techniques I can do those too
so that we're neutral we're the same
okay so now now that we've neutralized
at that level let's go to a level of
okay what else can you offer to the
situation and positional dominance
controlling existence managing the
dangerous strikes our skills that really
do Jitsu provides in an amazing land
people say oh well Jiu Jitsu doesn't
work as multiple attackers nothing the
common rebuttal I'm like yeah well bring
me the art that does I'd like to meet
that person me and my brother would like
to meet that person and then this is not
the first time this next guest is here
on the program we hadn't when the show
was just getting it see legs and now
it's back because he's back because it
ties into a news story I didn't even
know this before going into this you can
go to Gracie University calm of course
part of the legendary family that
created the UFC Hannah Gracie thank you
sir for being here
honor man I'm just glad that we're far
enough away where you can't get your
hands around my neck so I can't get my
hands around your neck good lord you you
and your false humility yeah actually my
necks gotten a lot bigger with the back
injury so I'm I'm up i fat-shamed myself
on air so that way I can go back and
then feel good when I lose weight so we
this story happened I mean they're few
things digging in into your obviously a
coach for Ronda Rousey they just
monumental the biggest you know female
in all of athletics right now but this
story happened you know this terrorist
attack in France that was thwarted by
Americans now I read about this I wrote
about this on the site but I didn't know
a key piece of information and you fill
me in on that so why don't you fill in
our audience who may not know right and
I'm sure the audience knows all you know
most of the general details regarding
the incident the train was on a was
writing from Amsterdam to Paris when a
man comes out of the laboratory with an
ak-47 pistol and a
a knife of some sort like a box cutter
of some sort and it has an ak-47 with
nine magazines of ammunition
ready basically 200 plus rounds and is
ready to wreak havoc and kill lots of
people on this you can assume right
presumably that he's going to kill a lot
of people and there's 500 people on the
train and the train car that he came out
with the weapon to you know kill the
initials I guess subjects or targets of
his attack there were three American
guys and one of which was an off-duty US
Air Force member who trains jiu-jitsu at
an affiliate of the Gracie family in
Portugal in Lisbon
Gracie lisboa and this guy is sleeping
and he wakes up to a commotion and a few
ak-47 rounds that went off near the
laboratory in between the train cars and
he wakes up and his buddy was sitting
next to him who I think his name is Alec
Alex biscuit Spencer stone is the name
of the juicy student and the man who
initially charged at the ak-47 so he
wakes up and Alec says hey let's go but
he doesn't even know what we're going
for he just knows that something's
happening crazy and Alexander he looks
up sees an ak-47 down at the end of the
hall or down at the end of the aisle way
in the train and just starts running in
his this is based on his kind of
recollection of the event he said at
that moment the guy was either the gun
had jammed or he was trying to cycle a
new round or he wasn't very proficient
and utilizing you but he was messing
with the gun and it wasn't shoot ready
so lucky for Spencer Stovall he kept
charging went straight through get a
hold of the guy starts to try to tackle
him Alec and Anthony the two other
gentlemen who were with him two other
American friends and they're both on
vacation in Europe charged in start
grabbing the a K and their Tesla for
another British man named Chris um Chris
Norris I think of Chris knowing Nolan
Chris something goes in there and he
basically is grabbing and striking - and
then Chris known as the director for for
Dark Knight I think you might be you
might be mixing it up but continue uh so
Chris something the British dude goes in
there all scuffling for this guy's
weapons and then Spencer gets behind the
guy puts him in a chokehold Jujitsu rear
naked choke yup eyes pressure is holding
the guys are able to take the AKA he
pulls out a pistol they take the pistol
then he pulls out a knife and start
stabbing Spencer and at that point is
when Spencer's ligaments and thumb
nearly get severed off I mean really
almost cut his thumb off cut his neck
and he's holding he lets him go pushes
him down they all start punching at this
guy you drunk ups the weapon they take
all the weapons you get back up
he puts the choke on again and with the
choke in place he's able to render the
man unconscious they're able to tie the
guy up with what looked to be like
seatbelts and ropes and t-shirts
basically tied this guy up kind of belly
down handcuffed position prone with his
feet tied to his hand so it was pretty
amazing that they're still able to
happen and my brother and I did a
breakdown and reenactment and kind of
discussed him three lessons that we took
away from this and you know it's just so
cool to see that he was able to engage
so quickly so selflessly and and and I
know for sure because it's where all of
my conviction and confidence and my
willingness to engage in anything not
just a physical altercation but any
aspect of life or any challenge as you
know comes from the confidence that
jujitsu gives us and and to know that
you're just played a small part in
helping render this guy you know
unconscious and ultimately subduing this
terrorist is uh is it is nothing short
of remarkable and I said in the video
that my brother and I made like it's
times like this where I wish my
grandfather was still alive so that we
can say grandfather listen and like
speak in a very simple language like you
like and say a man in you know France
was trying to kill people with an ak-47
he's like yeah I know the a K yeah that
guy was choked unconscious by a man who
does jujitsu with one of your one of
your son's affiliates Hoyer's affiliates
in Portugal and if you could wrap his
head around that and know how far our
judges to his travel based on his
efforts it would be it would be an
amazing thing but unfortunate is not
with this anymore
this is true well then also in his later
age that you laid sort of that filter
leaves you probably go on an anti French
tirade as to why the French cheated
Americans to save them I never note as
you never know there's a certain age
where it's like ah I don't care I'll
offend everybody and I've read some
interviews with your with your
grandfather Elia and he seemed to be
that way he was he was to the point but
sometimes really oh my god you probably
shouldn't say that yeah but at the end
of the day he was running out of time
into him who cares what he says for and
if he doesn't say what he feels what's
it worth you know that's kind of where
he got to I feel life right
no I think that's why most people get
their I think we're getting there as a
society too I mean here you have this
terrorist attack there's the time we
tiptoe lightly and not offend anyone I
think everyone's just so tired of it and
we're becoming a culture of people who
want to be more results-oriented we've
become so scared about offending people
listen if it's a Muslim terrorist
killing in the name of Islam let's talk
about it let's just be honest and face
the problem same thing
I think people now you see with the UFC
that you guys created are results
oriented in entraining for self-defense
I was talking about this and for those
listening to rest early we will have a
longer segment on ladder with Crider
calm because we know we don't want to
bore you with all the ins and outs
technically if jujitsu I was talking
with with my producer Jerry here about
this you know all these real combat you
know Krav Maga this is this is this is
reality based man I'm sitting there glad
you did su all that's it that's just
sport base I'm going to is there
anything more reality based than a
terrorist with an ak-47 on a train and
nine magazines and it worked isn't that
the laboratory of life isn't that and
you hear this all the time these things
happen all the time and effective basic
grappling works do you think there's
there's sort of a coming home to that
because there's been so much BS not only
in media but in martial arts there's a
lot of overlap do you feel like people
are just tired of it across the board
yeah I do and I think that you know
you're nailed it on the head at the end
of the day you know you can't argue with
the results and you know if you look
historically through all the martial
arts there's never been a martial art
that has single-handedly proven to be so
effective for some for the average
person right we're not talking about the
old track athlete who's giving some eye
gouging and growing striking skills
we're talking about average person
someone of average physical capability
to overcome someone much heavier much
stronger much more athletic that simple
engagement which is the probably the
most likely street altercation
engagement you can think of right
someone who's the bully or the aggressor
or the bigger stronger athletic threat
person dragged into now average person
who's not trying to pick a fight but
it's just out with his girlfriend and
some guy walks by with an attitude and
you know spit on him or hasn't as a look
or an eye or a tone or bumps into him in
a way or they to a certain what or nak
the point is it's always going to be
someone more
powerful again someone weaker in the
situation this most common and there's
no martial art that is proven that
ability to overcome that that's not
happening with eye gouges and groin
strikes that's happening with being
comfortable in worst-case scenarios
right at the end of the day if you're
fighting someone who's outweighs you by
50 or 100 pounds and they decide that
they want to tackle you they're gonna
tackle you and my grandfather's
philosophy was man if they're going to
tackle me great but the fights not over
until you make me say uncle well here's
one if you can't do that I'll take care
of the situation I'll submit you from
underneath you and I'll make it happen
so that's the the beauty of jiu-jitsu
its comfort in worst case scenarios no
other martial art provides the same
degree of readiness for the close
discomfort of a real fight right and I
would definitely say Gracie jiu-jitsu
for like so the unathletic person and if
you have people who are in better shape
you can include similar combat sports
where you're actually you know basically
having full-on resistance on a daily
basis what I find so funny was on my dad
about this know my dad's stud purple
belt never lost a point in the match at
55 years old we're talking about this
and you know the thing the big thing the
reality I'm using this term you know
loosely the reality self-defense arts
teaches well it's too limiting right
it's for it's for sport we would i
gadget hit balls I'm going to hold on a
second here's the beauty of something
like jiu-jitsu you're grappling you want
to talk limiting you could have used
this same movement pattern technique in
a in a tussle with your brother and just
slapped your little brother and gotten
him in line or with a guy outside of a
bar like you said he spit on you or you
can use more force and choke a terrorist
unconscious and tie him up he's like
waking up like boris and Natasha tied to
the railroad tracks there's nothing he
can do about it you get to control the
level of the situation as opposed to you
know these guys you see all of our
conservative shows and radio really yeah
I go to the eyes I go for the throat cuz
I'm not limited by sport well actually
you're so limited because you can only
make it work if you can get to the eyes
and like end someone's life not to
mention I know you know where my eyes
are and I know where your eyes are and
balls and anything the bottom line is
whatever you can do dirty techniques I
can do those too so that we're neutral
we're the same okay so now now that
we've neutralized at that level let's go
to a level of okay what else can you
for the situation and positional
dominance controlling existence managing
the dangerous strikes our skills that
really jujitsu provides an amazing land
people say oh well jiu-jitsu doesn't
work against multiple attackers nothing
the comment rebuttal I'm like yeah well
bring me the art that does I'd like to
meet that person me and my brother would
like to meet that person and then we
will engage against that person and
prove to them that what are they
practical they argue something that's
not it's like it doesn't work against
multiple attackers oh well you know what
kung fu doesn't work against the Acme
anvil that's dropped from the ceiling
onto you like Wiley coyote so once we
start dealing in reality that if you're
going to deal with four or five guys who
want to they're going to kill you
something that you know it works yeah
and you know it works against multiple
attackers is getting out of the fight
straight up getting out of the fight now
let me a hundred - so hundred meter guy
gotta get out but here's the problem
against two or three let's just say to
keep it simple against two determined
bad guys they want to attack you and
assault you what's gonna happen one's
gonna hit you the other guy's gonna grab
you though you're gonna fall to the
ground invariably if you stay in that
fight you will fall to the ground
because one guy's gonna grab you okay
unless it's a perfect knockout which
we've seen on some YouTube videos by you
know 10 15 year veterans of the striking
arts which is amazing if they have the
physical capabilities but I'm talking
about an art that is actually learn
about
by someone who's not a gifted freak of
nature so a normal person right let's
just assume their hold on a second
before we continue for those listening
who don't think this ties into culture
or politics it is important if you are a
human being to be a truly sovereign
human being to be able to protect your
life and liberty you can have all the
guns you want you can talk about the
Second Amendment you want if you're
unarmed and you're unable to protect
yourself you are not a truly independent
person just that's my aside there sorry
hen or continue but it's important
though you're not armed so you're
unarmed and you're truly independently
walking down the street and to crazy
un' independent individuals actually
interdependent individuals who rely on
each other to victimize independent
people like yourself come up and they
want to attack you and there they go
invariably that fight is gonna end up on
the ground so then my question is this
it's not oh who knows best jokes and
armlocks who is best capable of escaping
a inevitable ground fight to get
back to their feet and to get away right
so in jujitsu if for nothing else is the
skill to get out of a ground fight and
who better to teach someone to get out
of a pool than a swimmer who better to
teach someone to get out of a ground
fight then a jiu-jitsu master so we're
teaching people how to understand a
ground fight you can't get out of a pool
if you don't know how to swim so learn
jujitsu so that you aren't victimized
and what's crazy is that huh talk about
police talk about police you know
brutality talk about you know the whole
recent hype on you know use the forest
and law enforcement sure would I go
teach a law enforcement group I stand in
front of 5060 cops so I'm gonna certify
as instructors and Gracie survival
tactics for law enforcement I say guys
rule number one the bad guy always has
the ambush advantage you never know when
they're going to attack UFC they know
when the fights gonna start you guys
don't have that privilege number two
never grapple in a street fight by
choice
you guys have tools and tasers and
weapons and other tools intermediate
force options that once you're in a
ground grapple are available to you and
the suspect so do not allow your stuff
to be in a ground fight grab the ones
that we have to go keep the lesson with
a commercial we'll come back keep that
train of thought Henner Gracie schooling
us on how to beat terrorism yourself
with your bare hands a lot of with
crowder stay tuned we're back with Henry
Gracie was talking about training law
enforcement and I'm sorry to step on
your toes continue so rule number two
when training law enforcement never
grapple with the suspect or the enemy by
choice the idea that you have weapons
tools tasers baton chemical sprays you
know all of these are opportunities to
basically use intermediate force if you
can create distance but if you're in a
crap pull they're available to both
parties and a lot of law enforcement
professionals will say well I want to
learn jujitsu because I don't want to be
grappling with the bad guy as if we're
encouraging it's the opposite we teach
you jujitsu so that you understand the
ground fight so on a moment's notice is
you can disengage I whenever you want
access to other intermediate force
options and then of course neutralize
the threat in the most appropriate way
possible and then rule number three when
it comes to a fight for your life there
is no tap out the threat has to be
neutralized and the suspect has to be in
handcuffs or else we don't practice it
so these kind of founding pillars of our
program you know are really important
because a lot of cops say oh did you
choose growing an MMA but it's not for
long for
because why would you want to be rolling
around on the floor with the bad fact I
wouldn't want to grab the bag you arrest
them and you're a grappling by your
choice and then it turns south where you
end up underneath him how are you gonna
get back to your feet if you never learn
how to swim well not only that but if
you're talking about like you know the
black lives matter movement or people
who talk about police brutality if I'm
being arrested I mean you should be
these people should be lobbying for
jiu-jitsu to be taught in the force
because again I would much rather have a
cop who is in control who can lock me up
you put the cuffs on and not have to hit
me not have to whack me with a baton
that's that's the key and that's what I
want to talk about here for people
listening that the terrorist issue I
mean you guys deal unlike a lot of sort
of these these let's just call us it's
called a suspect BS martial arts that
God we're reality man we're hardcore
you guys actually deal with a psychology
of it and that's why you see these
results so often terrorists public
attacks whether it's in a pizza parlor
in a public pool it's about knowing how
a situation arises situational awareness
and controlling it it comes down to
controlling the situation and if nothing
else if people who don't want to learn
how to fight you know they'll hear
listen to I don't wanna learn about how
to fight but they want to learn how to
have situational awareness and control
the situation what what do you teach
those people when they come in an
absolute newbie who then goes from point
zero to beating terrorists with attacks
so the first kind of principle of
jiu-jitsu is that you know you want to
be comfortable with closeness so when
someone comes in we know that as a
culture Americans especially hi nice to
meet you we shake hands it's you know
compared to even Brazilian or other
cultures which are much more intimate
hugging and kissing and European
cultures it's still a very much of a
there's a gap it's always a safe gap
between you and the person you just met
and and that's pretty pretty interesting
so that when we get them to the Academy
our first thing is men get comfortable
being closer as you train jiu-jitsu so
we get them in there we show them a few
techniques on the ground we're grappling
we're teaching them how to be
comfortable that closeness once they're
like not all tense when they're close to
someone then we start to layer in the
actual kind of skill sets and techniques
the first most important of which is
learn how to manage the distance and
manage the damage and this is true
whether you're on a train with a man
Varian ak-47 or you're in a fight
against someone who wants to rip your
head off with violent punches in both
Kay
you won't either be all the way out of
the Train or all the way up on the guy
who has the a K you don't want to be
ducking down by your chair waiting for
him to walk by and execute you
point-blank
so this natural tendency for people to
just say Auto versus what Spencer stone
had as we saw clearly in his uh in his
report of the incident he just got up
and charged in that was a very jujitsu
principle to say I'm gonna go I'm gonna
engage get as close as possible as fast
as possible he knew that by being that
close the a K has very limited
effectiveness in fact the only damage
that was caused to to Spencer wasn't
even done by the 8k or the pistol was
done by a knife so the point B he knew
that that weapon was not dangerous if he
was so close to the person and this
ability to be comfortable with closeness
managed distance managed damage it all
boils down to teaching them the
techniques and once they build the
confidence in the Academy then he goes
back to the ability to avoid fights be
more aware of your surroundings and
ultimately prevent fights from happening
because people who fight are people who
have something to prove but if you are
able to prove your capabilities every
day in the gym you don't have to go out
and puff up and feel the need to you
know aggress people outside a bar or
wherever your not so big to that in the
middle because I want to say them and
this is going to be politically
incorrect people talk about how they're
Americans and they were so brave when
the heroes all of that is true but it's
not just bravery people need to
understand that this is a situation
where they had been before not exactly
but it wasn't false bravado
it was familiarity with a situation so
it's really really easier to say oh just
brave these people just brave hear us
will you go okay okay but what led to
that bravery and that's something that
everyone can learn you don't have to
depend on someone else for that that's
the mind that's the psychology of it
another thing to mention the box cutter
it's very important you know this is
this is more right-leaning politically
and it race he's not here to talk
politics but so a lot of people are into
tactical weaponry guns and knives a
knife is a horrible defensive weapon
there's no such thing as knife fighting
it's an assassination right if you take
out a knife you've now escalated it it's
not like a gun where someone's going to
go okay hey walk away people out there
need to know that because we've had a
lot of people even maybe come into the
studio with a knife this is my defense
well it's going to come down to a
physical altercation with a knife and
you can do all these
silly little you know Steven Seagal Mike
fighting moves all you want the fact is
you're not going to see a knife until
it's inside of you and the guy who's
gonna win a knife fight it's not like a
gun it's not a mechanical advantage it's
still a physical altercation and
someone's getting stabbed so I see a lot
ease and we just had another stabbing
out there in Detroit and well it's not
really news because it's Detroit anyways
I just that was just for the listeners
to hopefully educate some people out
there walking around with pocket knives
who got for bidding of Swiss Army knife
that'll just fall
fold on your fingers like a paper cutter
switching gears Ronda Rousey you're one
of her coaches obviously grappling
coaches she is like the biggest star in
all of I mean arguably in in sports
right now but certainly the biggest
female star you were with her for a long
what's it been like watching that right
it's become a cultural movement it's
like a new feminism it's not burning
bras you know smoking pot it's like
women want to see this strong chick
who's out there making it with her
achievements it's pretty cool to watch
ya know it's been spectacular to be part
of it and it just kind of comes full
circle right to have been involved and
to see the creation of the UFC over 20
years ago by my father and you know his
partner's way back when and to kind of
see how that was a shock to the culture
then it was like you know the AED you
know to the heart of martial arts in
America literally just boom it just
jump-started something and started an
entirely different movement and it feels
very similar to what Ronda is doing
right now for women's athletics more
specifically women's MMA she's giving it
a jump start that only a star like
herself could do you know and it really
took Ronda to begin that movement and
she's not just another MMA fighter she's
truly an exceptional athlete I really
have to go to realize what time was okay
stay around
Henner Gracie got a lot with credit calm
for the extended online version where
he's uncensored you won't even believe
what he says it's x-rated a lot of with
Crider calm stay tuned so what happens
now we just don't even know and now
you're not just online there's no breaks
or anything sorry but we have you know
it goes on terrestrial and they have to
do the break so you can just keep
talking about Ronda now you can say
whatever you want I'll start it off
urination there you go we set a dirty
word go ahead
no so anyways it's uh yeah it's been
truly magnificent and it's just cool to
see that you know movements special
movements take special people you have
to get them started and interestingly
enough we talked about this you know in
in in the Gracey breakdown of the
terrorist training salt that you know
leadership right and it just takes
someone to make that first step and
someone has to engage and it's almost
like Rhonda didn't choose to start a
movement she didn't have a choice
she is the movement you see them say
it's in her DNA this is just she is she
didn't change anything about her to
caused the movement that she's causing
she simply was brought up with with
incredible values and work ethic and
capabilities and she has the most
incredible skill set and and physical
set of attributes that I've ever seen in
an athlete and basically she was just
put in the you know in the Octagon to do
and of course the the precursors to that
was you know her you know other titles
that she wanted previous dude events and
whatnot judo and even you know the
events that she fought him before the
UFC but then she stepped in there and
she was the first you know women's UFC
fight and you know like I said it wasn't
even a choice
it was just destiny for her and we're
just lucky to be alive when it happened
and you know like hoist did his thing in
the early 90s and we'll it'll never be
undone it'll never be redone no one will
ever read ooh what hoist did for men's
MMA no one will ever really do what
Rhonda has done for one is MMA and it's
it's cool to have been alive to witness
both of these incredible movement well
question because I actually was thinking
of that comparison
I mean first time I don't think I'm
offending hoist by saying you know hoist
is nowhere near the elite level like
athlete that Ronda is that was the whole
point right he wasn't crazy intimidating
athletic he was an everyman who was just
had to learn jujitsu um but at that same
time no one really knew it so he was
just dominating those guys in the sport
evolved and you have the G s peas and
the Anderson Silva's do you think Ronda
is kind of at that point where they're
just I mean she's so far and about she's
leagues above everyone else where it's
just like they don't even know what she
knows she's too far advanced I mean even
see any real challenges for her coming
up yeah I mean it is tough you know and
it's comparable it's very comparable in
the same
that you know what what hoist was to the
you know athletic competitors or the
other martial artists that he was up
against Ronda is to her competition it
feels like that big of a gap in the
sense that it's like these women can't
even compare it to her and of course
that gap is created by several factors
the the most significant of which is the
fact that you know she's been you know
Oh 100% committed to martial arts you
know via judo since as early as she can
remember while mostly women who are
fighting MMA today began training MMA
you know not too long ago five six years
ago even eight years ago ten years ago
you know so Ronda is just it's just in
her DNA and you know her mom was a world
champion so it goes all the way back and
she was and brought up around so it
could she actually used to host them in
when they were in Michigan or maybe he
lived in Minnesota back then I don't
know but he actually used to like base
to sleep at his house and he talked on
how just like nutty her mom was as far
as just being so missed always on her
about training like he said she was just
like she was really you know she made
her train like no one else was making
their kids train and Ronda wanted it is
kind of incredible to see and obviously
they only fight out there right now for
her that people
sorry I don't you never want to belittle
an opponent but Holly Holm I was having
this debate with my friend actually Dana
I think you've done it Dana lash as a
another big radio show on her husband
and he was talking about Holly Holm
because he's a boxer he said well no one
else knows what they're watching done a
little bit of boxing I know a little bit
what I'm seeing there um it doesn't
apply in MMA if you look at Holly Holm
her stance in boxing where she won World
titles it's not even remotely similar to
the stand she takes an MMA when you have
to defend the takedown the hands are
down people go that's terrible box look
the hands are down and the legs are way
too wide yeah dummy they have to because
someone's trying to tackle you she
fights Ronda Rousey all of her kicks are
gone right away I can't see her it may
be a low kick so those tools are gone
then it comes down to hands and listen
they're women they don't knock people
out generally as readily as heavyweight
men right um I don't see any way she
wins that fight is that just like not
excited for it do you feel if you'll run
two runs that risk it's a point like
Tyson where people no longer buy the
paper views because they're like no one
has a shot
I don't know man people are buying
pay-per-views I think even Tyson sold
till the end there so I don't know man
that's a compliment but I mean it's
something there is you're too good for
known good it does yeah it does become
less of uh let's see if Rhonda's gonna
win or not and it becomes more of uh
let's see how and how quickly and how
impressively right you know and that's
still impressive and it's real a
challenge so it's Rhonda versus Fonda in
some regards Rhonda versus herself and
can she can keep topping herself keep
getting better and and you know there's
no doubt that you know based on what
people have seen and what you know
Rhonda is demonstrating is that she's
evolving every single fight yeah it's
obsessing the excitement how is more
let's see how big of a gap in in you
know in progress Rhonda has made since
her last fight so I think that can be
the height that can be what people are
excited to watch and with someone that
good the question is always can't she
get any better and the answer is she is
she's doing it every single day so if
not for the challenge of whether she's
gonna win or lose people will buy I
think and people are always gonna be
excited because she doesn't go in there
just to win she goes in there to outdo
herself every single time yeah that's
what people are it's like you can put
anybody on either side and we just want
to see Rhonda do Rhonda you know that's
what people are intrigued by this
question to become this international
superstar on multiple fronts it's
because they're just impressed with her
as a person as an athlete and as a
leader of a movement yeah and the cyborg
thing is obviously the one in the wings
that people are talking about firstly
okay let's let me ask you this because
you you obviously you know metamoris you
work with with Brennen shop I have to
ask you is there any awkwardness since
they dated and they don't date it's not
a secret it's all over them knows about
that is there any awkwardness for you
guys like the they come in at separate
times it to keep you in different wings
no there's no awkwardness and they're
both professionals and they're both
grown individuals and they're both great
friends of ours and life goes on Jitsu
all the way so you have to answer to
make me seem like an immature ass uh is
he going a little Ariel Helwani in there
let me get the background drama um the
cyborg thing it's one of those where I
go back and forth this is going to be
incredibly insulting towards cyborg so
my apologies but sorry not sorry if you
watch the way when she was competing it
I think was Abu Dhabi purple or was it
were
she won she went Abu Dhabi purpler
world's I don't recall you know how she
wanted was by being overwhelmingly
stronger than literally just like suplex
suplex suplex it wasn't finesse it
wasn't like Ron Rhonda's very strong but
her technique is for people who don't
her stand is superb I mean you'll be the
first to notice that her technique with
her throws is just unreal those are so
hard to do but that's how cyborg won if
you watch her grappling tournaments if
you watch her you know she pulled Mount
under Gina Carano twice um usually seems
to really overpower opponents Ronda was
willing to fight her a lot of people
don't realize this rana said okay I'll
win the 135 will unify it'll be like the
first female super fight right then she
pops for steroids that's what ran that
train off so a lot of people now say
Rhonda's ducking cyborg because she's
calling her down to a division um does
Rhonda ever get bothered by that or do
you as her trainer where there are
people out there saying oh she's ducking
because I don't really have the full
story because I mean that's that's like
the big fight that people want to see
right for her before her retirement is
cyborg sure yeah and you know Ron has
been very vocal about her stance on the
whole thing and one thing you learn
about Rhonda real quickly is that what
she says is exactly what she meets right
and you don't have to read between the
lines with her at all
straight up and if she said she was down
to do a super fight before she meant it
and if she said that that's crazy now
that she's popping drugs and that she
got popped for steroids that makes no
sense because she's cheating then she
also means that right and if she says
I'll fight her no question if she fights
me and she passed the test and she makes
135 I'm waiting right here so I think
it's a very fair thing I think that you
know it's been interesting to see you
know Chris build up the cyborg build up
the fight like trying to pull Ronda out
of her weight class but you know Rhonda
said it very clearly I think it was
actually Dana who said he said the
champion doesn't need to chase anyone I
have the belt I'm sitting right here
there's no 145 pound division in the UFC
I'm the champion if you want this belt
this honor and and to ultimately you
know carry this title you got to come to
me why am I going to leave my chair to
go chase you I have what you want come
get me come make the weight do it
healthily and I think yeah you know it's
possible you know her nutritionist says
that she's working in that direction and
I think that
it's never been so close I think that it
gets to a certain point where cyborg
realizes that all of the top trash
talking and all the poking and prodding
doesn't really do much not going to get
her anywhere and it's certainly not
going to get her anywhere near where she
would get if she committed to making the
weight lost the weight and actually did
the fight that would be the biggest
fight of career probably the biggest
fight of Rhonda's career up until this
point no doubt and the biggest it my
eyes as her nutrition it would be stop
injecting the bull testosterone that
would be my first advice that be my Mike
Dolce Gurunath but yeah listen you know
all those drugs are taken let's start
with ditch nose and you'll see the
weight so I hear that dog barking and
this is this that's actually have you
ever met Rhonda's dog mocha I don't have
it met okay
same kind of dog it's a dog Largent II
know all white giant thing that's
barking because my wife just came home
but beautiful well in cyborgs defense I
think she passed her last drug test you
know me her last fight so like she's
he's like whatever
no live your video and here's the deal
and you're like being such a diplomat
about this I'm sorry I know as you've
never been like a huge you about what
205 210 195 195 good lord cuz you've got
a big frame if you weren't a vegan you'd
be huge um so the guy walks are like
right now 230 I should probably be a lot
of e lot of vegan used to be queer I'm
totally honest uh you're either you're
vegetarian I'm a Gracie bro life goes on
okay alright alright I don't want to
misrepresent you I that's the perception
than the energy sandwich um that's when
I think of you I always think of the
Henry sandwich I picture you just like
coming out of the womb with an avocado
like oh let's make it happen
well isn't an energy sandwich has uh
eggs in it and isn't eggs non vegan does
it have eggs in it yeah bro three point
no you gotta check out the latest
YouTube video okay google it the energy
sandwich 3.0 alright alright I'm sorry I
didn't mean to slight you by implying
that you were vegan um but as someone
who's done a lot of strength training as
well I mean you know we've had maar
crypto on here who's like you for
strength training and he'll be like you
get you don't do that and then you guys
would be the other camp like don't do
strength training I fall somewhere in
the middle um once you build up a base
with steroids you don't lose it that's
right it's it's sorry once you do it
it's the same
reason the Fallon Fox thing for example
lobule don't understand this for those
I'm sure you know you've probably had
Fallon Fox on your radar because there's
a chance if she gets in the UFC
you know would fight Ronda Rousey the
hormonal advantage of a man / woman is
is so monumental and then when you alter
that as a woman with steroids I mean
you're talking it like ten to one
difference of testosterone it's such a
huge bigger factor in women's MMA than
men's MMA it's also much more dangerous
for women so for cyborg to do that it's
not even the same as you know like
Anderson Silva getting popped you know
fighting someone like shale who also got
popped um there were he's a friend he's
been on the show it's a huge difference
and so if I were Ronda yeah I'd twist
that knife a little bit too I think
there's a little bit of mental warfare
there where she doesn't think and I
could be wrong but I think I've heard
her say things she doesn't think that
maybe cyborg is that confident but you
know coming down without some
enhancements yeah I'm with that and I
you know that seems like it could be
true and I think Rhonda's 100% down she
wants the fight she just wants to do it
you know fair and safe and you know and
go for it but I think Ron is very
confident and I'm confident that Rhonda
would win the fight it just has to be
done on a uneven playing field
this is true so you're married now you
can have a baby yeah couple weeks from
now newest little Gracie family member
so we're super stoked first one and yeah
I've been helping a lot of people raise
their kids by teaching them jiu-jitsu
and giving them confidence and bully
proofing other people's kids and we'll
see if all the the training paid off and
I can do my own and do a good job you
know so it's pretty cool you know that
my favorite part about it is I get to be
a white belt again and started something
completely fresh that I have know
nothing about and be able to learn a new
thing right you get you get good at what
you're good at right and you kind of
stick to the things that you're good at
and it's not often that we get to start
something completely new and I get to
feel like one of my beginner jujitsu
students who's completely upside down in
techniques for the first time I'm going
to come home with a baby and not know
how to put the diaper on and it's gonna
be interesting I don't think you're
gonna be that adapt you make it sound
like you're Michael Keaton mr. mom like
a Disney cover I don't know what to do
I'm sure you'll be fun you've had what
like 125 boys and the grey
see family there's a lot yeah there's a
lot of boys were you um were you pretty
confident you're going to have a boy I
mean it just seems true no no no it's
not even yeah get to the point where
well it's interesting like growing up
you always think like all crazy family
we need to have boys more boys boys boys
number one mission accomplished right
the world knows you just you have see
what's created a whole bunch of people
got choked out and we arrived at the
Georgia two is essentially you know the
new karate
it's the art that everyone knows it's
about everyone should be learning
everyone wants their kids to learn is
the new martial art and but the
difference between what you know came
before is it actually works and is
actually effective for self-defense see
what is that and it's they you just did
exactly what I did but you did it in a
way that seems nicer I said like ah vs
these Krav Maga guys coming in
threatening and like you just you say
nothing and you make me look like a dick
and then you're like you know something
that actually works we all know what
you're implying you're just not the
truth is that the funny part is this I
have you know karate does work
everything works for what it was
designed for it right right one of my
best buddies just lyoto machida is one
of my best friends and when it comes to
knock someone out he's there's one of
the top guys in the whole world
because of his whole life of karate when
I say jiu-jitsu the best martial art or
when I say it it actually works what I
mean is it for a very specific
circumstance which is what a smaller
person against a larger opponent and a
larger opponent who basically is going
to tackle you and punch your face into
the pavement so it's a very specific
situation and for that situation
no martial art can give the promise that
jiu-jitsu can and that's where my
passion comes from not from you know I
guess I guess deflating the capabilities
or the utility of other martial arts
because for what they were designed for
every martial art is perfect it's just
that when you think about a real fight
which is most likely to go to the ground
jiu-jitsu prevails right but anyways I'm
excited to be a white belt in and you
know having kids and uh well you know in
the majors Tang because he I mean a big
part listen he'll he's talked about it
what allows him to open up his strikes
rights being pretty confident on the
ground
he's sumo - he's trained which a lot of
people don't you know know was a legit
you know grappling martial art I mean
talk about a guy's just impressive load
I mean the guys just his timing is is
second to none but you know the reason
it matters to me is the same thing when
you're telling my bully proofing kids I
think I've told this story
I told you maybe off-air um my dad
really wanted to get us in jiu-jitsu is
good I mean I was bullied really badly
right picture this okay so you're proud
Brazilian right well I was raised in
Quebec French Quebec I'm American and my
dad actually had this and if you don't
hear the story you can just you know
hang up and tell me it's important but
this is true I was really really bullied
a lot and um I was always hard-headed
but my dad realized wait we're in French
Canada my sons have to go to French
school they're taking Canadian history
you know they're not going to know who's
on the $20 bill unless I teach them
they're never going to know about
America and their roots and so he always
taught us that you know national anthem
he wanted us to be proud to be American
also because there's a rampant
anti-american sentiment when you're in
French Canada and so I would go in and I
would have teachers and kids tell me how
America sucked and all Americans were
stupid and fat and had too many guns
right this is what I was hearing inside
like no you know it really hurt me as a
kid so I'd stand up for it and then
eventually get my ass kicked it's
usually how it ended up going and so my
dad put us in the martial arts was a guy
taught karate and there he taught you
know I kick I Kempo Jitsu do one of
those things just you know made up and
then finally he had seen the UFC
this might have been 94 or 95 so hoist I
know came in a 93 he said hey jiu-jitsu
this is what you have to do I said I
signed you up for jiu-jitsu at the st.
Lambert at the st. Lambert Community
Center
well we show up and the guy who's
teaching it is the same guy who taught
the icuk I just it wasn't jiu-jitsu it
was jiu-jitsu toe something that he had
made up and he the first thing you tried
to sell us were these little glass
batons for your like your keychain like
weapons yeah and so he tried to but like
he tried we just didn't have access to
it and I just got my ass kicked and I
wish that I knew then what I learned
later as an adult when I cut through the
BS and you know my first instructor was
a guy named Fabrizio meda see I know
actually it wasn't actually I learned it
in high school I did judo with a guy
named Katalin goeco who was a Romanian
champ and then jiu-jitsu was later on
and I just wish I knew that as a kid and
so I hate it it's not so much that I've
mad at other martial arts but when they
lie to kids and they equip them to go
get their butts kicked that's what
happened to me you know they would tell
me like you tell that bully that he's
only Buzz's in a martial arts class you
tell him that that bully is only
bullying you because he
really needs to work on himself like
I'll do that and get the crap kicked out
of me cuz I can defend myself right so
that's restoration comes from you must
get that all the time right people
coming to you or like hey listen I don't
know what to teach my kids someone told
me you know what you're doing right they
just drop him off yeah 100% and the
people fly across the country we just
finished maybe three weeks ago we had
our summer annual bully-proof camp in
120 kids from all across the country 80%
r out of state and they come in for one
week and the parents are there and like
you know whether they've seen a YouTube
video that we've done some work or
whatever it's you know for us man jiu
jitsu actually works it's the perfect
solution for kids why number one it
works if you get attacked you can defend
yourself and at the very least even with
only one week of training you can at
least shut the bully down hold on and
not get beat up they don't hurt and then
principle breaks up the fight and know
both you go to the office and you're not
bloody you're going to the hospital
that's the best victory number one
number two is that if the bully attacks
and the and the jiu-jitsu practitioner
is able to overcome the bully with their
techniques that we teach them they're
never going to hit the bully they're
gonna control themselves so it's
restraint and we teach the kids that you
know you don't have to punch the bully
in the face you just knew immobilize
them neutralize them and wait till help
arrives so they're not we're not
creating bullies we're just putting fire
with water so to speak and then number
three above everything else is a catch
I'll debility too because what will
happen that kid comes home scuffed up on
the playground
dad dad kid push me today and trip me
while PE what's the dad gonna say hey go
back up to that kid and punch him in the
face or at least go back up to him I
tell him you know don't ever do that
again
the problem is asking a kid take that
your ass off yeah asking a kid to assert
themselves to a bully physically or
verbally whatever the parent is inclined
to recommend to their child ask me a kid
to assert themselves to a bully without
teaching them the physical techniques to
Bakula is like asking someone to go
learn how to surf like hey I'll teach
you how to surf without first teaching
right a swim in right not smart you
can't tell a kid to go punch a kid in
the face and not expect him to know
anything in response to what if the kid
retaliates solar jiu-jitsu is
essentially the foundation that gives
any child the ability to walk tall have
good eye contact assert themselves
and ultimately prevent violence before
it takes place because you know we would
say learning how to fight so you never
have to that's the core of Gracie bully
proof it's the corner of jiu-jitsu even
for adults the more you learn how to
fight the more jujitsu you learn the
less likely you are to ever have to use
it because you become so composed so
calm and so assertive in how you deal
with people that they're you don't get
on you're not very much on edge you're
not uneasy you're not unconfident you're
just ready to handle whatever comes your
way and people can sense that it's like
men either this guy has a gun or he's a
jiu-jitsu practitioner I can't tell
which one but he seems like he's got his
act together I don't want to mess with
him and that's the vibe you want to put
off no you're absolutely right it's
funny that you say I think Jitsu created
that awareness too when I was up that
Union incident in Michigan the footage
people didn't see was several guys
following me to my car making threats
now I looked in the sky was maybe i mean
you've met him pretty big guy this guy's
maybe about 5 foot 6 maybe about 130
pounds and he's following me he's
threatening me and say he's gonna kick
my ass to my car now if I hadn't done
jujitsu right and my ego wasn't in check
I go this little guy I mean listen I
could just throw them choke them easy
but I'm going why is this guy 130 pounds
stepping up to me 225 threatening to
kick my ass probably is armed
you know usually that's the case you
know he was very aggressive shoving me
getting in my way when I tried to leave
and and walk to my car and I said hey
can you just walk in front of me you
know say whatever you want don't walk
behind me get in my face and that was
because I knew okay there's something
going on this is not what usually
happens in a situation like this and it
wouldn't have happened if my ego weren't
in check you know I think that's a big
thing that's so important to about
jiu-jitsu it's really you get them every
now and then it was really rare to get a
guy come in with an unhealthy ego who is
just you know snapping partners up you
ever get those guys there in LA yeah you
have to kick them out simply enough well
here's the thing it's one of two things
happens when you get an aggressive
personality to come to a jusu class
right because the mat doesn't lie when
you get there you can have the biggest
ego in the world but literally in one
class all have come sit down to the
smile asides of like a walnut and we'll
just put it in the corner because you're
going to feel right away that all that
ego means nothing if you don't know
jujitsu extra
it up you're just completely helpless in
a fight without these techniques so you
can come in as tough and aggressive as
you want we're able to compress that and
just say hey calm down bro and then
right away one of two things happens
either a they flip out and they're upset
that their ego and that their pride has
been challenged and they can accept that
their perceived sense of themselves that
they've been story that they've been
telling themselves for the last 25 years
of their lives is completely falsified
and untrue so they kind of freak out and
they never show up again the other
people more commonly 95 percent even if
they came in with an attitude after one
or two classes suddenly they're the most
humble most respect or most in love with
jiu-jitsu transformative its environment
that we have going into the Gracie
Academy and in most juice schools around
the world bottom line is that ego cannot
survive and cannot flourish in an
environment where it's constantly being
checked throughout those white and blue
belt years where you basically you know
don't know anything and you're basically
being toyed with by more advanced
students you know there's no space for
the unfor the unhealthy ego there it
just doesn't it just doesn't clear
especially at the Gracie Academy where
there's an environment of servitude
respect and discipline really make sure
that those unhealthy egos are are not
able not know no foundation for them to
even grow yeah I know you got to go soon
I've idea it's funny I have a story
about that one of my closest friends at
jujitsu we became friends because we got
into a fight in class so what happened
this is a prime example of egos finally
than we both realized we were being
stupid what happened was full disclosure
I had a first instruct I had an
instructor who was sandbagging a little
bit because he knew I could compete and
he never gave me my blue belt at this
point at this point I'm a starched white
belt and I had to win tournament turn it
to get a blue belt some white ball this
guy's a three striped purple but I've
been a white belt for several years and
I was doing it six times a week and I
tapped this purple vote guy guy named
James more hi James and he got really
mad and so then he went harder and then
I went harder because I'm the white belt
right he's a purple I'm like it's not
your job Selina I went hard and he went
hard then we get up and we just started
yelling like frothing at the mouth you
know because he was going hard and I was
going hard were like okay so we were
fighting you want to fight let's go
outside and then afterward he calls
listen man you know the truth is I'm you
know you're a white belt and I'm a
several striped purple and I
like I was just it was ego and I've been
having a bad week and I said you know
also as a Christian I said you know it's
my job to humble myself and ask for
forgiveness and I said my temper got the
better of me and now he's super close
with my dad we roll as a matter fact to
the plumber we roll if it gets intense
will laugh me like you want to go
outside you don't laugh and then he
chokes me you know I mean it's such a
healthy relationship because it's so
hard to hate somebody when you're that
intimate with them and it's experiences
I think that if people haven't done it
they can't really understand I don't
question there's no doubt about it
no but it's truth you stated the truth
and I think that until you train
jiu-jitsu you don't realize how how
quick and how intimate and how real that
bond is many people come in from all
over the world I've never met them
before they show up we share the love
for jiu-jitsu we do a class together we
train for an hour and I feel like we
know each other I feel like man I want
to come all over you want to you know
stay at my house you want to have mine
just like you're just its family after
that it's so crazy and it's so funny
that it's so strong that you start to
like see someone wearing a Jersey
t-shirt and just by seeing someone
wearing a t-shirt you feel like you
already know them you like hey what's up
my friend where are you trained and you
want to care it's crazy like there's
really nothing else that's like that you
don't see someone wearing an NBA t-shirt
hey man were t-ball it doesn't happen
with jiu-jitsu though it's a it's a very
interesting culture that very
interesting family doesn't matter who
you train with if you train jiu-jitsu
you still feel that man there's a bond
we've been through much of the same and
and I think that's one thing that holds
us all together and it's also why it's
so easy to sniff out fakes you know
they're also gone black belt in Tai Chi
jiu-jitsu toe oh really under who Bob in
jiu-jitsu if guys like I'm a black belt
I can ask a few questions and figure out
if it's legit pretty quickly cuz it's
not easy to do it I mean it's like who
gave it to you well um I'm at one time
at a guy tell me he was a black belt in
jujitsu
so really under he goes wow guy Mezger
now guy masters my dad's gym where he
trains him guy measures a brown belt
he's like no no black problem you just
won brown belt world and masters guy
much like he's totally healthy he goes
like no I've never promoted anyone to
black belt in jujitsu like it's
completely wrong and I just kind of
played it off my swing last me yeah so
how's it going you know that black ball
under under guy or eyes like oh yeah man
you know I'm just I'm going to keep
going for my
can stripe it's just so easy to trace
because it's such a small knit community
do you recognize coming in and doing
that like all Madame black belt
it's like made-up no not so not at the
Gracie Academy I think that's like
that's just too much miss Trent come on
like you can get away with that like a
small town in Texas but not here in
Torrance like where this thing is kind
of a center for movement and everyone we
2.4 and introduce anyone in lineage so
it's not ah excuse me because it's a boy
like I'm about to finish perfect right
recording all right well we're losing
your connection there and you want to go
back because your missus is is going to
have a baby soon and you have way more
important things on this Henner thank
you so much we have to have you back on
you're good with the news you're good
with it you should you know stick with
it you're good with this stuff I'm not
here it's a big time I'm not hearing you
but it's going away so thank you henna
Gracie and appreciate it we'll have you
on some time soon good-looking guy 195
not a vegan my apologies enter Gracie
we'll see you next week if you like this
video you have low standards but you
should subscribe by clicking my face or
watch one of these other videos you just
may like them of course ladder with
Grider comm has a lot of things that
aren't videos I mean you know videos
here non videos there you can do every
that you just have to make one click
here as opposed to typing in the intro
carpal tunnel and plus you might have
gout with the thumb just just click